海外が昇りたいなんかたくさん階段登ろうと思ってツイッターで打ったんですけどもう
ツイートされた分階段登りますって言ってもうすぐ10ずに趣味きりって言ったんです
けども今が時間が勝ち越す9分あと1分でございます10時までの間にどれだけう
ツイートされたかで僕が階段どれだけの50か大きめます増10時になりました
これが
最後のコースんですはい
[音楽]
ni
じゃあこうよん
[音楽]
4日
ああもうこれ以上からで辺でこれ見られたのですよね
コッコロスタートだチェッカーズでこっから登っていくと
平がめちゃくちゃつ付いているので
稼げます
色ネット twitter だと登りますって言っちゃったんですけどあのくだりも
入れないと多分時間が足んないんですと降り大キツイんで紹介だって歌にも込めて階段
の上り下りように今の839弾繰り返します
ね1159だから
上り下りするだけで脳料理するとこの値になりますと今839大2318ではってこれ
で往復が出るということでしょう
2003で部2発
て発展99だから9往復すれば目標達成ですねこの記憶でしょ
new york full と20806図2段階目の上り下りしたことになります
この階段を9往復
するよ
リツイートされた分だけ階段を上り下りしたというん
ええええええ
こんな風に最初は比較的ねあ
乗っていたします
じゃあ頑張ります
さあ
本当に楽しくれますそれから
th
持っています
はいずっと張ってこんな光
ん
あっつばであれこちらで
いやっいやっ
ああああああ
[音楽]
tan
しています
th
[音楽]
me
なめてたでいただきますわー
[音楽]
ん
ええええええ
はこれでこれで片道でしょ
上からこんな圭佑だよそれがこれで今やっと
西100物球団
よし
戻ります
ん
[音楽]
me
パターン生ですあ私はロワーし
よし1318
あった
バーっマッチキツイんだけど無理かも話し月を含めてきます
先はまだまだ長いこれを後初回繰り返すのである
果たして彼は無事に版803ず球団の回転を制圧することができるのだろう
次回予告
疲れ切る俺
小学生たついにすごい騒がれる俺
終わりと足に限界やりそうな俺
うっ倒れちゃった俺そこらへんの物価ってグッドエンディング出来てる奴らに任せる俺
俺楽しくねもうコート着たい
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
あっはっ